how in the world is this old machine
actually working this well has the
macbook air really gotten that much
better in the last decade well today we
will find out because we have a 2012
macbook air right here compared to the
2022 m2 macbook air and get this both of
them have eight gigs of ram and 256
gigabytes of ssd which is crazy for 10
years difference not only are we going
to compare some benchmarks in real world
applications but i want to see what is
the difference in the speakers the
webcam the display and connectivity i
think you'll be quite surprised with
what is different and what might be
actually similar or better on the 2012
version let's start out with the design
now i think it's crazy that this thing
is only three pounds for a 10 year old
machine steve jobs pulled one out of the
envelope that was just a shocking moment
and even now it is so slim and
lightweight but with that said the new
m2 it is lighter at 2.7 pounds and if we
take a look at the actual footprint it
is substantially smaller in every
dimension now apple did finally get rid
of that classic wedge shape which is a
bit of a bummer but on the thicker side
the new m2 model is definitely slimmer
and has a lot lower volume overall we
have a couple other major changes here
apple was still using that plastic hinge
instead of metal and then of course the
classic glowing apple logo that would
have been so cool to have on the new
macbook and now let's touch on
connections because this is where it
gets interesting back in 2012 we had
magsafe 2 it worked great you had the
little led that would pop up right now
it's fully charged and apple finally
brought that back
with the new mac safe of course now we
have this beautiful braided cable
everything's in a die so it's much more
premium but it's nice to see apple
change their mind and go back to that of
course this also has fast charging which
the old one did not have now we also
have a usb on this one we're gonna test
out the speed and a headphone jack on
the left side which is where i prefer it
because i use my mouse uh in the
trackpad with the right hand side now
the macbook has thunderbolt ports those
are obviously very powerful but they are
just on the left side circling over to
the right side look at that even the
macbook air had an sd card slot which
was great and it was thin the new one
does not have that we only have a
headphone jack here and then we have
another usb plus a thunderbolt port now
the new m2 macbook air it only supports
one display
the old one 10 years ago it actually
supported two if you're connecting over
thunderbolt and they also have a few
adapters that can split that out so it's
crazy that we're more limited now than
before and now what i want to do is take
a look at the inside we know the new one
is fanless let's see how much the
internal design has changed and look at
all those screws we have 10 of them and
they actually use the same bit as the
2022 model but that one only has four
screws all right the screws are out
and
yeah you can literally just lift it up
you don't have any retentions or things
you have to pull
so that's it
and look at that right there
we have a very clean design a lot
cleaner than i expected
obviously we have a fan although it is a
very small one smaller than the newer
macbook air so we'll see how that does
thermally we have a proper heat pipe
here where our cpu and integrated
graphics are
and right over here this is probably the
wi-fi or the bluetooth chip it's
removable so you can upgrade your
internet which is great if you're buying
an old device and then we have our ssd
right here it's a standard m.2
and you could just unscrew it and
upgrade it yourself now as i mentioned
this is 256 just like this macbook we'll
check the speeds but you can actually
put in up to a two terabyte if you buy a
specific one or you can do a one
terabyte for a hundred bucks which you
can't do with the new models we have a
lot of battery packs over here nice and
clean beautiful design and we have these
speaker modules that are massive i mean
look at how much room it takes up
they're using all of the space that they
can use whereas now it is much smaller
so i'm very excited to hear the
difference in the sound quality opening
these back up the first thing you notice
is the difference in displays both these
are technically 13-inch displays but
with the old one we have these massive
silver
bezels that stand out like crazy
compared to these slim black bezels on
the new one the ones that are all
rounded of course we have the notch
there for the better webcam which we'll
test out in just a bit now below that we
have this classic macbook air a little
text or logo it looks great i wish apple
kept it on the new one and
with that the display differences i mean
this thing is not nice to look at if
you're used to these new apple retina
displays the bezels i can kind of get
over with but i see every pixel here
around all the text all the icons it is
crazy now that is because we have a
resolution of 1440 by 900 which is
actually pretty good when it came out
but apple stuck with this display all
the way until 2018 when we got the
redesign so we have a difference of i
don't know three and a half times the
pixels on this display and here
everything is gorgeous very sharp you
can't see any pixels at all now the
difference isn't only sharpness if you
look at the colors and the contrast it
is crazy how much better the new retina
display is
the 2012 all the way up to 2017 was
using a tft display that lacked contrast
lacked color accuracy it was very
unaccurate not great for photo or video
editing and in general it was the main
downside whereas with this 2022 model it
is now 500 nits so it is brighter and it
supports one billion colors with dci p3
color accuracy so it is
massively better i actually ended up
downgrading in a way from the macbook
air to the 12 inch which was a lot
slower for productivity in 2015 because
of that display i needed the accuracy
well before i cover the webcams and the
speakers i want to talk about the
keyboard and the trackpad now some
people were saying
that the this was the time of the
keyboard apple had the best ones and
then they made a lot of mistakes and
that's true but at the same time the m2
has a way better keyboard the actual
keys themselves are larger they are more
stable they're a little bit concave and
it feels a lot nicer and it's more
accurate to type with the new one than
with the old one with that said the
difference in track pads is even greater
this is before we had the magnetic
force touch track pad so it's a diving
board design it's easy to press at the
bottom much harder towards the top and
even when setting up this laptop for
this video i was getting frustrated with
it because the new trackpads on the new
macbooks are amazing they are a joy to
use better than any other laptop out
there and lastly of course we have touch
id which makes it faster easier and more
secure to log in and authenticate your
mac and now i'm excited to compare the
webcams and the speakers now looking at
the cases here we don't have speaker
holes on either one it's interesting to
see that apple went back to this 2012
design and got rid of them now with the
new one we actually have speakers right
up here that fire up through the vents
against the display whereas the old one
you guys saw the internals they have
massive chambers there but they fire
through the keyboard itself now i gotta
say i'm a little bit nervous to hear
this out and hear what kind of
difference we get but let's go ahead and
take a listen
[Music]
[Music]
where are the mids in this laptop we
actually have surprisingly good bass i
wasn't expecting that in the highs
they're not too detailed but they are
sharp they're there they're present but
the mids are gone and with the new one
apple really focused on a nice balanced
sound
it's not much louder but i mean the
difference is massive and now let's
compare the webcams and the microphones
this is the m2 air's new 1080p webcam
which has been improved in a tougher
situation we have a window right behind
us and this is the 2012 macbook airs
720p webcam so yes it is 720p which is
crazy but you guys can see it is
struggling in this situation now moving
into a more controlled environment this
is the m2 macbook air and this is the
2012
intel macbook air looks better because
it's not struggling with that window but
it still looks pretty terrible it also
looks like maybe we're dropping frames
here and you guys let me know what you
think about the audio quality down in
the comment section below and now i'm
really curious about the performance if
you're gonna buy one of these for 180
bucks that works and has the same ram
and ssd
how fast is it can actually keep up with
regular use and what about some
productivity i want to start out by
testing the cpu performance this thing
has an i7 processor with a fan compared
to apple silicon's m2 that is fanless as
i mentioned both have 8 gigs of ram and
let's go ahead and run this geekbench 5
test all right wow this thing is hitting
100 degrees in geekbench 5 102
that is higher than the newer intel
macbooks those were capped about 95 and
even 98 it would just slow down a lot so
these could get hot even in simple tasks
alright we have results and bam
that looks like a huge difference at
least on the surface as far as the
multi-core score we have a difference of
over six times higher or faster on the
m2 macbook air as for the single core
score it is actually a little bit less
than three times more performance with
the new one you guys may have heard the
rule where every couple years was
supposed to have a doubling of
performance in this case that didn't
happen we had 10 years and it didn't
even triple for single core so i was
expecting maybe a bigger difference now
i'm curious what the low power mode will
do for the m2 macbook air if you didn't
know i actually did a whole video on the
low power mode and how amazingly fast it
ran for the little power usage that it
had while staying insanely cool even
though it is fanless we have our scores
and the multi-core is four and a half
times faster still but the single core
is only 60
faster
now with that said this intel chip is
pulling a lot more power and if you
didn't see that video you have to watch
it after this one now graphics is where
i think we're going to have a much
bigger difference because the intel hd
4000 uh well it was very slow compared
to apple silicon where we had a huge
jump in graphics performance so let's go
ahead and run this okay guys it has been
three minutes now and we have barely
even moved on this progress bar here
while our temperatures well they're
getting quite hot and the fans are
starting to spin up here so thankfully
we have geek bunch of sites i'm just
gonna look it up alright guys so uh
somebody recently ran it and we have a
score of
100 compared to 26
1558 i don't even know the multiplier
though that is crazy uh so we're gonna
see how that affects real world usage
but from what i could see you don't
really wanna buy this mac uh for
graphics tasks the cpu isn't too bad but
graphics man now we know that the base
m2s have much slower ssds than previous
m1 models so i want to see how fast is
this ssd let's go ahead and run this
blackmagic disk speed test so this is
actually not too bad we have 383
for right and 448 for read so we're
looking like we're about 3 to 3.8 times
faster on this new base model with the
same capacity now i think the m.2 in
here was probably upgraded because i
think the factory it was slower than
this but if you would upgrade to say
that one terabyte for a hundred bucks
you would get closer to 500 for both of
these which is surprising for a machine
that is 10 years old now i plugged in my
external ssd and i'm surprised that the
speeds are actually fairly decently
quick too with our usb connection as
well so this is actually pretty usable
even in 2022 if you're not doing
anything crazy i'm also curious about
the thermal performance with this fan
it's an i7 but it's a dual core so i
have sin bench open and i'm going to go
ahead and run just one run of our
multi-core test because i know it's
going to take a long time and i want to
open up intel power gadget and it looks
like we hit a peak of about 17
watts right there we're actually a
little bit higher than that it's kicking
in even more so so that looks like
the peak power that is used whereas on
the macbook the fanless m2 we're over 20
watts so this is a fanless machine
that's more efficient running apple
silicon is using more power now we're
already at 103 104 degrees here
dang
these things it used to get much hotter
than the newer generation i'm talking
about like 2000 2017 ones 2018 ones our
fan is starting to kick up but it is
still slow at spinning up compared to
um you know other windows computers and
other systems so right away we're
getting some throttling now and at the
same time our m2 is at 108 degrees
celsius so even hotter and it's running
a lot more power now this thing will
slow down all the way to about 5 watts
if you're gonna be doing this for an
extended amount of time if you didn't
see the video where we added a fan and
we tested out a laptop cooler with the
thermal pads that makes it run at peak
performance for pretty much ever it was
great you guys should watch that video
too i'll link both those at the end of
this one our fan is now at full blast
6500 rpm and that did actually allow the
cpu to use more power and to speed up
but as you guys saw that fan was tiny so
it is still running over 100 degrees
celsius in order to achieve this
performance it's running right about
three gigahertz which is a lot better
than the advertised 2.0 gigahertz at the
base so that is quite impressive running
at about 18 watts
of course here we have an eight core
processor with those efficiency cores
and we already have our score that was
fast and it's quite high so i'm
interested to see what we get here
running about the same amount of power
but a lot more cores 10 years later
looking at the temperatures with our
thermal camera the hottest point seems
to be
47 49 right there at the top
so that is actually hotter
than what we get with the m2 macbooks
now some people say that these things
get too hot the bottom gets too hot
but apple's actually controlling these
more so than before we finally have our
score and we have a thousand three
hundred and eighty five compared to
eight thousand five hundred ninety five
so a difference of just over six times
the performance so since they averaged
about the same wattage and ran at
similar temps that means we have an
efficiency improvement of about six
times over the last 10 years which is
quite good now let's take a look at some
real world tests now as i was setting
this thing up i was quite surprised that
the web browsing experience
wasn't as bad as i expected now sure
some things take longer to load ads take
longer to load which is a good thing
but it just was fairly decent so what i
want to do is test out our speedometer
2.0 this is going to show us our web
performance for things like simple
browsing open up different javascripts
apps things like google docs sheets and
we have a score of 76.9
a lot better than i expected this is
actually not that much worse than my
2019 mac pro
now the empty machines they are insanely
fast we're looking like about five times
faster you do notice that it's snappier
but this is still very usable if you
want to pick up one of these for a web
browsing machine for 180 bucks now as
far as creative things like photo
editing i actually did photo editing on
a macbook air that was not much faster
than this 2012 and it was painful as you
guys could see when you're switching
photos it does take a lot longer i mean
here i'm already ahead each time i
switch this one is almost instant even
though it has a slower ssd whereas this
one we have the little loading bar
and then it adds in all the effects and
if you want to use brushes
actually
that is not too bad on this raw image
i'm pretty surprised
let's go back to just our standard
corrections
that is not bad that's better than
microsoft surface x that they had i mean
a few glitches but not too bad now let's
go ahead and export these 50 images our
empty macbook air is flying and it's
using both the cpu and the graphics
whereas with the older one it could only
use the processor the graphics are way
too weak and it is taking forever to
export that was a painful 10 minutes and
11 seconds compared to 2 minutes and 16
seconds so almost 5 times faster for the
new machine now with that if we would
upgrade the ram and the ssd it would be
about a minute and 16 seconds a lot
faster when it's equipped properly
without the bottlenecks of the ram and
lastly just because i'm curious let's
test out some video editing using final
cut which is the most efficient for slow
max
and here you guys see
we're probably playing back at one frame
a second maybe our cpu is maxed out
we're using the graphics compared to
perfectly smooth here now of course we
do have some effects let's go ahead and
drop it to better performance this
lowers the resolution let's try this
again
and that did not help now it's
interesting that the quality actually
got better of the video because this
display has such low resolution
but it's still so stuttery maybe you
shouldn't even dare to want to export
this but let's go ahead and try we are
crawling along using only the cpu no gpu
whereas the m2 is using mostly gpu and a
little bit of cpu now that is of course
because the m2 chip has really good
media engines with encoders that make
this very fast and it's getting close to
done whereas the 2012 is still at zero
percent that is crazy our m2 is done and
it has now been three minutes and we
just reached one percent here now
there's no way that i'm waiting for this
to finish so i took that time for one
percent i stretched it out and it would
take roughly 4 hours and 35 minutes
compared to 2 minutes and 20 seconds now
of course we are exporting the hevc
that's what this footage is all the new
stuff is shooting that it's uploading
better with that so i'm going to cancel
this and try h.264 all right so that was
a lot faster we're looking at 26 minutes
compared to the four hours or more
compared to two minutes and 20 seconds
so still a lot lot longer with that
codec
it just shows you you should be using
that old one and realistically for photo
editing and for video editing it's not
really a great machine but if you just
want to do web browsing and some simple
tasks what other machine can you buy
that's 10 years old that is actually
going to run properly that can web
browse decently
and i think this thing came with an
updated battery too so it's not dead
it is not bad any windows laptop would
have choked and died a long long time
ago so there you guys go for simple
tasks even just simple corrections in
lightroom it did a shockingly good job
but when it comes time to the displays
the speakers in any type of tougher
productivity we have a huge amount of
improvement in a fanless machine here in
2022 if you guys enjoyed this video
check out those other two i recommended
right over there click above to
subscribe if you want to see more videos
like this one this has been max and i
will see you in the next video
[Music]